the one and only my dear friend Happy
New Year judge Janine Piro uh judge
great to have you back Sean thank you so
much for having me all right it's kind
of simple to me they did hold Steve
Bannon in contempt didn't they they held
Peter Navaro in contempt um I I thought
we had Equal justice and equal
application of our laws so I would
assume the Democrats that voted to hold
Bannon and and Navaro in contempt are
going to hold hunter in contempt right
well Sean you know what I I believe in
the criminal justice system I gave my
life to it but I have to tell you the
more I see this the more I I become so
disillusioned look they're preparing a
resolution for Congress to hold Hunter
Biden in contempt not only is he in
contempt because he defied a
congressional subpoena but he thumbed
his nose at Congress and the American
people when he actually went out and and
held a media event and basically said my
father didn't do anything and then took
no questions he said look I want to do
this in in the open I don't want to do
it behind closed doors look you don't
get the opportunity to tell Congress how
they should or shouldn't interview you
so the bottom line is if there's any
justice in this country he will be held
in contempt the way Bannon and Naro have
been held in contempt but you know and
now we hear that his sugar brother Kevin
Morris uh is giving him money they want
to do a documentary on his life so we
see him as the great father that he is
but for the child of the woman that
doesn't like and what a great painter
and what a great worker he is so this is
all about PR and hiding from the truth
all right so Democrats now they're
trying to claim that well Donald Trump
owned a hotel in Washington DC and
people from countries like China Saudi
Arabia cutter whatever that they
actually went to the hotel and they're
say see Donald Trump got paid by Foreign
governments and it's against the iments
Clause uh the only problem is there's a
big difference isn't there between Joe
Biden going against Obama administration
policy after taking a call from Hunter
and two barisma Executives that
desperately needed DC help because they
wanted the investigator in Ukraine
Victor shoken fired there's kind of a
big difference that he leveraged a
billion dollars and as a result of His
official actions Hunter continued to get
paid uh for sitting on that board with
no experience at a time when he was
addicted to uh pretty hard drugs uh any
comparison in your mind there's
absolutely no comparison Donald Trump
wasn't involved in the in the business
once he became president the bottom line
is he had properties he was entitled to
uh have someone else monitor those
properties and make money from those
properties okay now let's talk about
Hunter Biden Hunter Biden was supposed
to register under the foreign agents
registration act anyone who represents a
foreign country interest interest in the
United States is supposed to register in
fact this lawyer named I think it's
Beretta uh ends up retroactively
registering as a foreign agent because
he as a lawyer represented aleski who
was the president of barisma at exactly
the same time that Hunter did now the
fact that Hunter didn't register as a
foreign agent and this guy registered
retroactively I can show you another
example of the inconsistent Justice
because Paul maniford tried to do the
same thing he said let me register
retroactively and they wouldn't let him
and he ended up going to jail but the
truth is that Hunter Biden Not only was
representing a foreign interest in the
United States he called his father as
soon as lovesy the owner of or the head
of barisma called he said Dad we got to
get the prosecutor off this case or I'm
not going to be able to make any money
being on the board three days later Joe
Biden goes over he leverages our tax
dollars Sean that was a billion dollars
of our money they get the prosecutor off
and together they end up making sure
that the Biden family gets all the money
that they need and and you want to call
that that is corruption it's a violation
of Farah and you know Hunter Biden is
going to be arraigned on I believe
February 11th on nine towns in Los
Angeles related to tax charges but not
foreign agent registration act you know
why because that will connect Joe Biden
and they don't want to look at Joe Biden
they allowed the 2014 and 15 years to
pass the statute of limitations because
that's when Hunter Biden says me and my
dad are watching here we want $10
million this is a sad commentary on
Justice and and today Joe Biden gets out
there and talks about democracy on the
ballot it is laughable Sean all right uh
judge happy New Year hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
inter inters and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else